what was your hardest time in our
marriage I think the turning point in
our relationship from East happen when I
turn 40 that's when I had a midlife
crisis yeah
your 40th birthday was my low point Jada
Pinkett and Will Smith getting real
about their relationship on a red
tabletop he's at a time in his life to
where he is he's healing you know and
he's also kind of breaking down some of
the construct that he's built around
himself of who he is and who he's not
and all of those kinds of things so I
actually think that this has been kind
of him coming to the table has been kind
of a release for him to not have to live
up to this yeah I'm sorry it's been work
and it's not easy and it's and they can
be painful so and I'm proud of him the
couple's of marriage as they knew it
fell apart after will through Jada and
over-the-top 40th birthday party that
she says was more about him than her
she's told me that the party was the
most ridiculous display of my ego Oh
crushed right and to this day I know I
was crushed
because it was true and this is that was
a display that moment of like me having
the courage to just say no no but now I
had to have the courage to unravel it
and just realizing this next 40 I gotta
do it my way
Jada says up until that point she was
trying to live up to an idea of Jada
will had created instead of just being
Jada to have to let go of the picture
yeah to have to let go of the dream was
devastating we essentially had to
destroy our marriage oh yeah
I needed more freedom and freedom in the
sense of like you know you can the
public wants you to be a certain way
your family needs you in a certain way
your partner needs you to be something
you know and for me that just was never
you know I'm really a free spirit at
heart I really am and I always have been
and I just felt like my life had got
constricted into this little box and it
was strangling me basically I was
devastated
even worse than a divorce we we broke up
mm-hmm
within our marriage and got back
together again had to rebuild with new
rules and something way different
something way completely different the
couple was never headed for divorce
though they just took their relationship
down to the foundation and rebuilt we
don't even call ourselves married yeah
you know it's a life partnership in the
sense that we've created a foundation
together that we know is for this
lifetime this lifetime we have devoted
ourselves to each other in a spiritual
sense will said he retired from trying
to make Jada happy and empowered her to
find happiness on her own the things
that Jaden needs to be happy I'm not
going to agree with them all right I
truly have learned the definition of
unconditional love and to me that's what
it's about people that very rarely talk
about the courage it takes to be happy
how much bravery it takes to be happy
and really that's what I needed to gain
was the courage and the bravery to do
what Jada needed to do to be happy you
know and that was to dissolve everything
that was and creates something
completely
today with all these new rules in place
the pair says they've never been happier
I always knew I'm not marriage material
what I am is ratted I chick what you are
is the best friend that I've ever had